[Musique]
la FRCA le département de La Réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la Réunion vous
présente terre
[Musique]
d'ici on trqué le stylo enfin la souris
et et le clavier pour le C4 Jean-Luc
Pellier n'a pas hésité à quitter le
confort climatisé de ses bureaux
d'études pour suivre Marie Noël sa
compagne dans la réalisation de son
projet agricole alors responsable de
magasin Marie Noël à pavoupoulet décide
un beau matin de suivre une formation
agricole au CFPPA de Saint-Joseph ben
j'ai fait la formation et je me suis
pris un goût au fur à mesure je me suis
pris au jeu comme on dit et et j'ai fini
la formation j'ai réussi la formation
j'ai eu mon diplôme j'ai concrétisé on
va dire en décembre 2012 j'étais
officiellement agricultrice et la SER
c'est montée l'année dernière donc en
2013 2013-204 à cheval plus précisément
le 26 décembre 2013 c'était un jeudi
avec l'aide de quelques amis Marie Noël
et Jean-Luc s'attaquent alors au montage
de la structure de leur serre ben nous a
commencé un landemain de Noël en fait n
terminé en disons
mi-avril voilà pour commencer à planter
en en mai très vite les jeunes plantes
de tomates grandissent et s'épanouissent
en donnant leur premierers fruits pour
la jeune agricultrice et son compagnon
c'est alors aussi une grande première
première fois pour tout là première fois
première production de tomates première
fois avec tous les les soucis qui peut
que s peut apporter hein et première
fois dans la la vente première fois
dans dans les paiements première fois
dans les prêts première fois dans tout
ben on n'est pas fier à 100 % mais on va
dire à 80 puisque on débute on a fait
quelques petites erreurs qui vont être
corrigé au fur et à mesure mais sinon on
attend avec impatience la
deuxième la deuxième production pour que
ce soit mieux encore mieux
perfectionniste Marie Noël aurait
apprécié un peu plus de soutien
technique au démarrage de son
exploitation mais malgré les difficultés
du départ elle ne regrette pas
aujourd'hui son choix d'être devenue
agricultrice une nouvelle vie pour elle
et sa famille j'ai fait ce projet je
l'ai monté bout par bout et je l'ai fait
pour avoir une autre vie donc c'est
l'objectif premier donc l'autre vie elle
est là maintenant il faut
l'assumer dans tous les sens du terme
beau ou
mauvais
[Musique]
jeune agricultrice Marie Noël à
pavoupoulet a installé son exploitation
marécher sur le terrain familial à
Sainte-Rose son diplôme agricole en
poche elle met en place au début de
cette année cette S avec l'aide de
quelques amis et de Jean-Luc son
compagnon depuis quelques mois
maintenant le couple récolte enfin les
fruits de leur première production de
tomates l'année prochaine on fera
mieux voyez là c'est c'est plus gros
déjà là c'est déjà un peu plus gros moi
j'aurais espéré toutes les tomates comme
ça mais de toute façon le pied de tomate
il fera les tomates qu' fera hein on
donne ce qu'il faut à manger à boire au
niveau de l'engrais tout ça mais après
il y a a il y a plein de choses qui
rentrent en ligne de compte par exemple
là si on regarde on a les beau jages à
faire on fait au fur à mesure on passe à
côté on fait et au fur à mesure il faut
faire ça en fait faut remonter il faut
effeuiller pour que la la Tom la tomate
puisse puisse murir parce que s' a trop
de feillage dessus est dessous comme ça
pas la lumière donc mux pas mais avant
d'aérer les tomates pour favoriser leur
murissement il faut d'abord procéder à
la fécondation des fleurs une opération
quotidienne très importante ah oui parce
que si on féconde pas tous les jours et
ben on n pas de beau fruits déjà comme
on a montré tout à l'heure ça donne des
petits fruits le pollen il est dans dans
la fleur en haut là et lorsqu'on on la
secoue par exemple on fait tac tac comme
ça ben le pollen il descend dans le dans
le petit tube là et ben ça fait con et
ça fait ça ça fait des petits fruits au
bout de de tris jours quand même pas
tout de suite c'est pas instantané mais
il faut le faire tous les jours par
exemple sur une gra comme ça euh là
celle-là elle a pas été
fécondée mauvaise fécondation celle-là
ben c'est là cl oui c'est bon quelques
semaines plus tard les tomates sont
arrivées à maturité Marie Noël les
récolte alors au bon stade car ces
tomates bien rougge sont destinés au
marché de la transformation avant on
récoltait beaucoup en avance mais là on
essaie de de jongler avec le temps parce
que sinon les tomates sont trop mures ou
pas assez alors ça dépend faut pas
récolter par exemple la veille pour le
lendemain des fois on on dit ah ouais
mais ça rapporte pas assez ou bien ça
produit pas assez on a trop de problèm
mais finalement quand on regarde avec le
recul et ben si finalement on a on a
bien travaillé on a bien travaillé on
peut faire mieux on peut faire beaucoup
mieux mais on a quand même bien
[Musique]
travaillé